-Do you feel light-headed?
Charlie, look at me.
-She was trying to help him.
-Who?
-Ellie.
She was trying to help him.
She just wanted
to send him home.
Do you ever get
the feeling that...
people are incapable
of not caring?
♪♪
People are amazing.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Brendan Fraser,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from "The Whale"
with the aforementioned
Hong Chau
doing exactly what you said
she's so good at.
When did you...
As a young person,
when did you decide that
acting was the path for you?
-Pretty early on.
My family traveled a great deal.
My father's work was
with Tourism Canada,
and so every three or four years
we were somewhere new.
Our family lived in Europe
in the '70s.
And so, that was Holland.
And from there, we would take
holidays to the UK, London.
It's where I first fell in love
with museums and parks
and the theater.
And we would --
My mother would send us off
while they went shopping.
And we'd get tickets
to see anything we could
get our hands on,
"Jesus Christ Superstar"
or, you know, "The Mousetrap"
or whatever funny old mystery
that was onstage.
And it opened up like
a giant toy box to me,
and I thought,
"I want to do that."
I want to be a part
of the stories that I read,
and I show them to people,
and it feels like
you're included in it
and it's a living story.
And I think that's around the
time that I first started --
first sort of got
the bite for it then.
-And did your parents
celebrate this choice?
Were they excited
about the path?
-Yeah, they were.
They were very supportive.
My mom actually wrote the check
that got me into college
when I got the last
absolute final audition
before the Labor Day weekend
to start the new semester,
and I was stone-cold broke.
And they didn't tell me
if or not it was accepted.
And I called on the following
Monday morning
to ask, you know,
"Am I coming in?"
And they were like,
"What's your name?"
And I told them, I heard someone
like going, "Doo doo doo,"
you know, dropping phones
and that kind of thing.
And they went and picked up
a card and went...
Or, I heard them
with a Rolodex or something.
Like, "Fraser? Brendan?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
They were like, "You're in.
Get over here, now, now!"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Okay!"
So, it was off.
-A real professional operation
they're running.
-Totally. Yeah.
-They must have put actors
in charge
of running
the office as well.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you know,
this film received
incredible response
at the Venice Film Festival.
Standing ovation.
I know, you know,
you've had a career
where you've had many highs,
but did this feel special?
Did this...
Were you standing there
thinking, "Wow, this is
an incredible moment"?
-I was thinking I might be out
the door real soon if I hurry.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
And, 'cause, you know,
clapping is hard.
It takes a lot, you know.
-When you -- Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You know. Ow!
[ Whining ]
-But you read about, you know,
especially at these
film festivals,
you sort of read about these
seven, eight,
nine-minute ovations.
-I think it depends on
who's holding the stopwatch,
to tell you the truth.
-Okay. Got you.
So there's maybe a little bit
of a heavy finger?
-I think. They're Italian.
"It's a-seven a-minutes!"
"It's a 25 minute
standing ovation!"
-But I will -- you know, as much
as I wouldn't want to stand
and clap for seven minutes,
I feel like we sometimes
underestimate how hard it is
to stand for seven minutes.
Because at some point,
you can probably only go like,
"Thank you, thank you" so much.
-I just broke out crying.
That solved all the problems.
-Oh, that's perfect.
Perfect solution.
There you go, everybody.
Did you have a moment in your
career
where you thought,
"Oh, I made it"?
-Um...
Nope!
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't.
I feel like I'm still waiting
for someone to walk in
and tell me that
the jig is up, you know.
They haven't found me out yet,
but I know
that I'm doing what I love,
and it's a privilege.
I'm really happy
to be able to do that.
-You, um...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know that obviously we talked
about the difficulties
and how arduous it is to go
through the amount of hours
in the makeup chair
for these prosthetics.
-Yeah.
-With that said, I know,
you know, you also have been
in films with a lot of stunts --
"Journey," obviously,
and "The Mummy,"
"George of the Jungle."
Did you -- Was it nice to be in
a film where you didn't have to
worry about hurting yourself
doing a stunt?
-Oh, just my feelings,
that's all.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's...
Oh, feelings,
we got plenty of those.
-I got more.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, it is so nice
to see you again.
Thank you so much for being here
and congrats on the film.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Brendan Fraser, everybody.
"The Whale" is in theaters now.